so legally blonde is 20 years old we've
talked about what's accurate let's talk
about what's not accurate about this
show now let's commence with our usual
torture
one l classes at harvard being taught by
a practicing lawyer not going to happen
the 1l classes are usually taught by
some
very prestigious professor who is only a
professor there are practicing lawyers
who teach but not in your 1l year and
not
at harvard law 1l is competing for an
in-school
internship you will also be competing
for one of my firm's highly coveted
four internship spots what you don't
have a job when
you're in law school at least not at the
top law schools you just simply don't
have time and you're not going to be
competing
for some firm's internship while you're
in class it's just you don't have time
for it
you're fired i have new representation
letting a first-year law student try any
portion of a
major homicide criminal case not gonna
happen that's insane
and of course the most unrealistic thing
law students having a social life
no way is somebody at this school
actually having a party
not in your first year you're not this
case is dismissed